hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to you left me now this is a
serious game about a serious topic that
doesn't mean that it's not gonna have
laughs that doesn't mean that it's not
gonna have interesting moments but I've
just been told that this game is
relatively serious so we're gonna get
right into it and move right along it's
one of those games where you go through
learn the story and there's multiple
endings to it so we got to wake up Oh
work wake up work sleep wake up the next
day I woke up in the same bed but a
different world where am I
why am I here I don't know nice guy nice
okay sounds like I'm underwater oh oh on
the moon clicks a 12-hour timer what
happens when night falls when time runs
up how do I get out of here before then
I do why am i in a hand oh okay
hi kitty hahaha you gave me this cat I
love him like you had around him I feel
comfortable no need to pretend yeah
something doesn't seem right maybe it's
a big glowing eye in the middle of his
face but I hear I remember how he looks
up close I haven't spent time with him
not since although I talk to him hello
uh ooh what did I name my cat I've had
him for a while now yet I can't remember
seeing yo dog Oh senior Awful's is good
but I gotta go with dog oh hey dog oh
look at that Gator County dog Oh Argo
how you doing I'm pretty proud of that
one thought of it myself
I did hey dog oh you pee everywhere but
I
you anyway MooMoo boy my dude my dude
you're awake good snug last night Oh
alright how do I get out of here now
this isn't normal I don't belong here is
that bad
normal isn't always a good thing you
know
Oh hat bork bork bork bork all right
scratch scratch
boof butter food stupid oof I will marry
you platonically I love you I'll leave
you to sleep now
Yip ruff yes mam I still you make me
happy
nay I heart you too
Oh moo moo moo hee-haw
you're leaving already okay love you
please come back soon foreperson snugs
all right love you too
oh okay it's now 8:40 for what does that
mean my phone unseen text missed calls
I rarely look at my phone anymore I try
to forget about the memories it contains
how does the pancake wobble read notes
hmm
white messages read and heard your
banker trouble okay they read they read
I'm trying but I can't read them I see
words but I don't understand what they
mean try again I I don't know what's
going on I feel like my mind is working
against me
I can't focus I can't stop thinking
about horrible things I feel like I'm
going crazy oh no it's going to failure
try again that's me that is me after a
few attempts I get it oh okay how does
the pancake wobble the magnets ask the
first sticky note reads daily reminder I
love you from you-know-who not the hair
Potter kind the second note reads reads
remember Swain's Lane why the third now
trees give this girl some milk
all right that's enough fridging I guess
it's still 844 so I guess I could look
inside the fridge I'm positive there's
nothing look anyway
I found my keys in the freezer I thought
I'd put them in my pocket how'd that get
there
did I put that matter I need to get my
memory checked no no how you do that but
okay all right I guess that's enough for
today clock the moon rumbles that's not
something that the moon should do just
thinking funcle' in about it about
myself get out of bed oh I am on a
rocket ship to space where do I go I
need to escape this world before time
runs out aah what's going on outside
I haven't noticed before now Everwood
okay every day the bus passes the same
flower field
you wouldn't like this I wish I could
show this to you
oh all right the flowers are gorgeous I
never learned to appreciate small things
like these until you came along
the flowers are gorgeous I never learned
to okay all right read that okay let's
go to Swain's Lane I remembered that
Swain's Lowe
I remember now you died a while ago and
I've been denying it since but you
wouldn't want that with you me stuck in
my head living a fantasy there's so much
more of reality to explore the CAD you
left me the flower fields that passed
the metro
I loved you you know you left me behind
I don't blame you for leaving every day
I wake up and think about joining you oh
[Music]
that's heavy there's only one choice for
me
there's no given in as is this is a hard
fast rule it's something that is
completely against my character but it's
tough but I'll keep a living if the
memories you gifted me without you
I think that's one of the endings
dedicate to everyone who's lost anyone
thanks for playing
it was so short I was so sweet oh but
that's not the only ending that's not
the only ending that's tough
it always is losing someone especially
if it was someone that close to you but
let's explore the game a little further
and then I'll make some judgments toward
the end of it get out of bed oh the
flowers are still there that's weird
I can't even go to swings Lane let's go
anywhere I'll go anywhere I don't care
where as long as it's far away from home
hours pass I don't know where I am I
don't know why I'm here we used to have
fun taking the metro together and
leaving a random stops without you there
is no fun with how you repeating the old
memories just makes me feel lost by the
end of the adventure I feel like I left
a little of my soul that every place I
visited the park a hill inside rooms
outside buildings noisy streets
soft-spoken alleys night finally falls
when I get back on the bus to head home
no one's there the loneliness is
suffocating
[Music]
Oh
to size of an unfair coin live and die
those are two of the five endings more
of a succinct to abrupt end to that
story so there's got to be like
apparently it seems like a lot of it has
to do with where you go in in the world
but maybe it has something to do with
like the other interactions that you
have not that you have a lot let's go to
work
oh no oh god it's the crushing monotony
of an Amazon Fulfillment Center do I get
to interact with this no I guess I don't
our roof oh oh
[Music]
maybe those are the only like two
endings just the circumstances are
different you live or you die but then
this one in particular the the living
one is remembering I'm honestly kind of
curious I I know it's probably not
terribly good but there must have been a
reason to get like the keys the phone
doesn't work right now let me try
talking to the kitty getting that all
sorted alright so we talked to the kitty
you make me happy love you too
let's see about the phone huh I still
can't look at the phone no why you just
can't look at the phone anymore that's
weird
oh I can't go to Swain's Lane either I
wonder why it's kind of disabled now
let's go to the clinic observe the
doctors always look so happy with what
they're doing it makes it that much
easier to spill every thought you have
to them but I can't tell the truth I
don't know how how can i when I don't
want to remember wait in line now wait
for a very long time just as I was
beginning to lose hope they finally
called my name
sorry about the wait our latest
experiment and Happiness didn't go quite
as well as planned so I had to do some
crisis intervention enough about me
what can I do for you today let's see
how do I get out of this world
excuse me can you repeat that how do I
get out of this world
sorry I'm not trained to help you with
that Oh signs of psychosis possible
insanity oh don't mind me I'm just
taking notes did you need anything else
my mask is cracking it looks fine to me
can I try something else instead let me
see would you like to try our newly
patented happy pills one day we'll keep
the sadness applaud baby sounds great
thank you
of course let us know about your
experience see you around
alright I guess go home home I guess I
can go to Swain's Lane now which is
weird still can't read that take happy
pills I want to forget about bad
thoughts so that I'm only filled with
the good with every pill I feel myself
lose grip of reality a little more
remember a little less I need to forget
it all to forget it all I'll take it off
I'm sorry that's rough this is all rough
I mean the thing about this is it's it's
a story about something that's not
inherently good like this the thing
about this game and the thing about the
content that it's trying to talk about
is that it's not a good situation like
there's no right answer about like how
to get to a point where you can
rationalize it or you can you can
understand it it's it's about accepting
something that's completely out of your
control which is something that no one
likes no one no one wants to do I mean
I've lost people and I've known people
that have lost more than I have and many
many more than I have
oh that's so weird wait I still have my
happy pills
wait is this all persistent that's why
the flowers were still there that's why
I can't look at my phone anymore
I talked to the moon
wonder if there's the moon has new jokes
every once in a while I know it's been
hard
what's loud and sounds like an apple an
apple I know you want to give up what
class did Karl Marx struggle with the
most the booze wha what's Brown and
rhymes with snoop dr. Dre do you feel
alone what do you call a dog that does
magic tricks al abracadabra door I
didn't mean to leave you what word would
mean a lot to you right now
plethora what's the difference between a
well-dressed man on a unicycle and
importantly dressed man on a bike attire
media what did you forget who did you
forget what happened to them the moon is
silent child you're relentless
you have tired me I need a nap what are
the humans feeding their offspring these
days Tide Pods whatsit the moon is
napping peacefully oh I guess napping
peacefully let's go back to work and
then let's go home when we're done talk
do I have to socialize like a full
functioning human yesterday you said oh
boy oh hey hey how's it going oh hey
what's up why are you I won't add a
socializing Oh why do you ask I mean our
jaws why are you here
you've been taking this day off for
weeks now ever since I mean
anyway why are you here I just wanted to
you wanted to you okay
you ride in the head let's see I'm fine
why do you ask
I really think you should talk to
someone bottling up emotions just
doesn't you know what do you mean by
that I mean you've been to her gaze
right yes okay well I just want to say I
can go with you to go I know from
experience that the first time is
scariest that a challenge
homeboy not one I can beat I'm glad I
talked to you we rarely talk we need to
change that hmm don't feel any better
for report oh ok hi oh boy hello and a
decent job as always of course there's
always room for improvement
hey what do you say about working late
tonight hey you can improve and I can
give you a closer feedback I don't want
to improve packaging boxes there's a
great opportunity for you trust me on
this ah no thanks you sure you me alone
is causing legal yeah I don't know how I
got him off my back but I did just
another long long day alright go home I
guess
Swan Lane I remember now
I've been here before I have every day I
wake up and think about joining you
I think I get the point of this game and
why is persistent because the point is
and the reason that it's persistent is
that it's an everyday battle like it's
it's a desire to fight every day you
don't just wake up one day and be like I
accept it I'm done I'm over it I I'm
good I'm I'm stronger than that I feel
strong about it like that's not what
it's about like loss stays with you for
your entire life like it can heal and
you'll be fine you'll you'll be better
for it but you'll always remember it and
like the temptation to give in is always
gonna be there and it'll always pull you
back that's why you got to stay strong
because you know you survive one day you
can survive more and you can keep going
and then you can keep living even if it
can't seem like you will I know it's
hard and I'm not the best person to give
advice about this but I knew that this
game was gonna be serious and I knew
that it was going to tackle some pretty
heavy topics of death but if there's one
thing I know and there's one thing that
I said the beginning this video is that
it's not in my nature to ever give it
and I could hit this button and you know
I would see like I would see another
ending that I haven't been seen before
but for me personally I'm never gonna
hit that bad not it so I might choose to
survive again
I'll keep with it with the memories you
gifted me without yeah it's tough it
really is it's really tough there's
nothing that I can say or do that makes
it easier and there's no advice that I
could give any of you who are going
through loss right now but you're just
knowing that it does get easier it
really does and it's not easier because
you forget how important they were to
you it's easier because you appreciate
all the good times that you shared
together and you appreciate all the
memories that you have I mean this game
articulates it very well like you
remember the things that they leave
behind it and you remember the lessons
that they taught you the moments you've
shared in the laughs that they gave you
even the frustrating times you know the
bad times you remember those two and
that's not a bad thing because that's
literally what life is all about it's
about good it's about bad it's about
sharing experiences with other people
and that never ends until it does and
you don't know when it's gonna happen
you don't know if it's gonna happen well
I mean we all know it's definitely gonna
happen but you don't know when so the
only advice I can give is to do as much
as you can for the people around you for
those that you love to spread as much a
joy as possible and don't like it manas
yourself for any bad times that do
happen but do learn to forgive both
others and yourself when you can so
anyway I'll leave this one here if you
want to see what that ending is I'll
leave a link to this game in the
description below but just I know given
the subject that this is I literally
can't press that button I hope you
understand that about me I just can't
because it's not in my nature
I've learned a lot about myself over the
years that I've been an adult and part
of that comes with a lot of life lessons
that I didn't choose to experience but
did anyway so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you are going
through any pain right now reach out to
someone else in the community who has
gone through the same thing there's tons
of people out there and there's huge
support groups out there that are ready
to talk about it and help you and help
you through things like loss and pain
and depression so just reach out where
you can and know that if you are not
going through that and you see someone
reaching out for help when you send them
some positivity and just send them an
encouraging message so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know he thought down in the comments and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]